all right adam what's up brother how are
we doing so you had spoken with my wife
uh
katie uh exactly what it was
um but we had the four kids and she's
been dealing with um frustrate or
depression issues and i'm perceived
as being frustrated which isn't
necessarily going to be far
off um with it
but i also kind of want to get your
opinion on how can i make myself more
emotionally
available for her when she goes through
these spells
all right so before before we go any
further adam
easily the coolest guy i've talked to in
a long time
okay i don't know what kind of husband
you are behind closed doors
but the but here's the thing i called
you
out on this show which goes out to a lot
of people i thought i was just going out
to my mom they gave me some
numbers the other day it's a lot and i
your wife called in she who said she was
struggling with depression
and her she was frustrated that her
husband was frustrated about her
depression right
and i called you out i said why don't
you have him call me
and then dude here you are you called me
this is like high school when i'm like
once you have your boyfriend call me and
then you knock on my door you're like
hey what's up bro i heard you're talking
about me so this is it adam and
the fact that you're from waco texas and
the fact that you can't shoot me from
there makes this conversation
way easier right but i want to
just straight up acknowledge that
there are there are just not a lot of
guys of character like you
who want to support and love their wives
who are willing to put it out there
and who are willing to be vulnerable and
say man help me out if you
put your money where your mouth is big
guy and um dude i'm grateful for you
adam it's a very
you're very impressive young man cool
cool deal
all right so how can you help your wife
give me an example of something
that is frustrating when your wife is
having a depressive
episode and it's just frustrating give
me an example of that
well um with that
an example would be like um she gets um
real big emotions um with the depression
and stuff
and for me is i'm not a person of big
emotions
so to me i'm just i guess where my
frustration comes from is i
have a hard time comprehending what
all's going through i'm one of those
people like i see a problem here's a
solution
execute done and
i i guess i i'm at a um
i just don't understand
what she's going through with her big
emotions um
an example uh would be uh yesterday
morning
um ended up waking up freezing cold
um i go to get up before everyone else
uh turn the heaters on in the house to
warm it up
i can't find the lighter for it
i end up asking her if she knows where
the lighter is and she kind of goes into
a little spiral first thing in the
morning
about not knowing where the lighter is
and then she's apologizing to me about i
don't know where i moved it i don't know
where the kids did with it and i'm just
and my mind was like i was just asking
if you knew what the lighter is i wasn't
accusing you of anything like that but
then it kind of started her off on a
bad day and i just i don't know sure and
that's
the kind of example you're talking about
i love it
so hey let's so let's let's just dig in
on that example man
and um man
i just love your heart okay so here's
the deal
this is a common common thing we've
talked about a lot on this show
we will continue to talk along about it
i'm gonna speak in big broad
generalities and so if you don't like
generalities
send me mean emails or youtube comments
if that makes you feel good
most or a lot of men
are trained they are socialized just
like you
okay just like me and that is
there is a problem let's just solve this
problem
using a chisel and a hammer and a saw
and data and a fact and then uh
an achievement ta-da let's move on right
yep and so when somebody that we love
and that says loves us comes to us and
says
i'm so sorry i am feeling this way
and feelings and emotions and feelings
and emotions
your first thought was probably oh god
almighty dude i'm just asking where the
freaking liner is
go back to bed what are you doing and
then it's i'm so sorry and then you're
like
what are you sorry about stop being
sorry i just asked if you know the
lighters you know the lighter
is man and then it turns into this whole
conversation with
okay right so um
particularly somebody who has a history
of trauma which if i remember correctly
she she had some some some
some demons that have followed her
through most of her life is that fair
yeah yeah she had some early childhood
there you go
anxiety she's got yeah she's got some
stuff
um she's got some stuff back there um
it may be that a man early in the
morning
saying hey where's this boom
that sets off that alarm and man it
ain't coming back
and you and i will probably never know
where that alarm
originated from where it started from
but i can tell you this
sometimes that that alarm is chemical
sometimes that alarm
is hyper-emotional sometimes it's
physical sometimes it's all of it
and so what i want you to do in these
moments is to
not default to advice
data or facts okay
i want you to think of your wife not as
a problem to solve
but as a person to be with and this is
going to go way against anything you've
ever been trained or taught okay adam
so here's what i want you to do the next
time
something spins out because here's what
i remember from the last call
you love this lady don't you absolutely
you married her you have a kid i think
with her with your own and you adopted
her other three kids is that right
correct yeah yeah and i remember her
telling me that
you loved her and if i remember
correctly she
really loves you is that right oh
absolutely shows it to me every day
okay so the next time you
are just buzzing through the day hey
where's the lighter and then she
flies up in bed and you know you know
her enough to know now oh here we go i
want you to walk over
and say give me both your hands and i
want you all to watch this when it comes
out on youtube y'all can watch it
together that way you know
that she's gonna do it with you i want
you to sit down by her
and grab both of her hands if that's
safe for her and if it's even if you can
get away with putting your hand on the
back of her neck
and holding one hand or put your hand on
her face
and i want you to look her in the eye
and i want you just to look at her for
five to ten seconds that's it
okay and i want you to breathe as calmly
as you can
and then i want you to tell her i love
you it is all good
and i appreciate you trying to think
through if you knew where the lighter
was
but i got it from here i love you and i
want you just to step out
okay and the more you hover and look and
she's going to interpret those as
judgments because her brain at that
point is scanning for any possibility of
disaster any possibility of discomfort
any possibility of not
safe even to the point that her brain
will skip
data for close enough he just raised an
eyebrow that probably means he hates me
he's pissed off right and you're like
what are you talking about just sneezing
um that there's some wiring issues right
and i hate machine metaphors but that's
the truth um
her brain's just the the it's set off
there and then i want you to
encourage her to ask her hey would you
be willing to save up some money
and see if we can go to one of these um
family counseling services here
because i want to know ways that i can
love you better and i'd love to get a
professional here in town
and hopefully she's working with a
doctor on her depression she's working
with a counselor
i don't remember exactly if she did but
i encourage her to go get one
i want you to say i want to learn some
skills meet adam i want to learn some
skills on how i can love you
and be the best best best husband we
we are here now we love each other so
good i just don't have any skills in my
tool kit i don't have enough wrenches
and hammers in here
in fact all i have is a wrench and a
hammer and this knucklehead on the radio
said i need to learn some more stuff
and so i want to take you and i want to
do it and i know we can't afford it but
we're going to scratch and claw and
figure it out how to do it
and then we're going to go learn some
new skills together and what you're
going to do because she needs to learn
these skills how to connect to
she needs to learn that you are safe
safe safe safe
and that's going to take trust that's
going to take practice and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
double down on connection
not facts not oh my gosh you're going to
lean in
to that discomfort that oh here we go
you're gonna you are gonna go first adam
you're gonna grab both of your hands
tell that you're safe you're safe you're
safe and then i also want you to do this
i want you to start taking care of some
what i would call the ons and the offs i
want you to ask her what are the things
that just bring you the most joy in the
home
and i want you to when you get up to
light the furnace which again you're
such a great guy adam
when you get up to light the furnace in
the house to make sure everybody's got a
warm morning when they wake up
if there's still cups in the in the in
the kitchen get those
if there's some clothes that your kids
left out grab those real quick i know
you work your butt off brother
i know you do but do those little things
start looking around for ways that you
can make her home feel safer
and safer and safer and man that's such
a gift so here's what i want you to do
after you have gone to a few family
counseling sessions after you try
a couple of times to lean in hold her
hands hold her face
look at her eyes and say hey hey i love
you i love love love you
and we're just gonna sit here for a
second
and then once you get up and then you go
find that stupid light or wherever it is
um i want you to call me let me know how
that goes okay you guys are awesome i
love y'all i love walking alongside you
and katie this is so cool and again i
appreciate you being a man of character
but i want you to call me back and let
me know how that's going